welcome to this special edition of
discover Germany DWS travel guide
today's program is devoted to the
country's capital Berlin a constantly
changing city although it's been 25
years since the fall of the Berlin Wall
the German capital is still shaped by
its nearly three decades of division
countless landmarks still bear witness
to the city's Cold War history but
Berlin is also changing at a rapid pace
especially in those areas along the
former border widely consider the
livable multicultural creative city it's
become one of the most popular travel
destinations in Europe
the splay river flows through the center
of the German capital for almost 800
years it has both divided and connected
Berlin
in olden days a large tree trunk was
lowered to block the water way at night
and prevent ships passing unnoticed
there's bridge marks the spot it is one
of the loveliest bridges that cross the
spray
when the Berlin Wall was built in August
1961 the spy River became part of the
border between West Berlin and the
communist East a few days later East
German border guards shot Ginter lit
Finn as he tried to escape to the west
he was the first victim of East
Germany's shoot to kill border policy
after the peaceful revolution of 1989
potsdamer platz was transformed by new
high-rises the district is now a symbol
of the huge changes to the cityscape
following the fall of the Berlin Wall
after reunification Berlin once again
became the capital of Germany while
preserving its history the city also
built a new modern government district
the architecture is intended to express
transparency and the government's
closeness to its citizens
Museum Island is home to five major
museums and their many treasures the
latest building to be renovated is the
noise Museum its most famous exhibit is
the bust of Nefertiti
the renovation work deliberately left
scars from the war as a reminder of the
building's turbulent history
the Jewish museum's floorplan and
interior space is reminiscent of an
unraveled star of david' the memorial to
the murdered Jews of Europe consists of
2711 concrete slabs of different heights
creating a pattern of waves turned to
stone it's located only one block south
of one of Berlin's main landmarks
brandenburg gate berlin is always on the
move during the daytime and especially
at night
as the night continues the rhythms
intensify and the beat gets faster the
berlin club scene gets off to a late
start continuing until dawn Berlin is a
city with something for everyone the
city on the che River monuments of
architecture and entertainment round the
clock
almost every tourist to berlin pays a
visit to a site where the wall once
stood that's certainly true of jeremy
hexam from canada who's very interested
in Cold War history
we accompanied him on a tour around the
city
my name is Jeremy hexam I am from
Calgary Alberta Canada where I am doing
my PhD in political communications at
the University of Calgary today we're
going to look at the history of the the
sites of the Berlin Wall which fell
November 9th 1989
a good part of the Berlin Wall is
actually still marked so we're going to
go on our trip to the fall of the Berlin
Wall trail
just it's amazing how society a group of
people government could do that to
people it's just unreal I'm here at the
famous checkpoint charlie just down the
street over there
it's a checkpoint charlie marrow museum
I want to go in there because it should
have displays that show how people
escaped through over and under the
Berlin wall as well as what life was
like and I'm really interested in just
what it was like living with the Berlin
wall in the middle of a divided city
you
this museum is incredibly interesting
not only does it give the history of
checkpoint charlie and the way people
escape which I thought it that's all it
would have it gave the history of the
Berlin wall and a lot of the information
about with GDR
behind me is one of your last original
guard towers still standing in Berlin
the reason I wanted to come to this top
tower was simply because it's the last
one standing and chance to go up and
actually see what it looked like and to
see what the guards would have looked
like when they were on Patrol I see a
lot of grassy field I see trees but it
gets back in the DDR days what I'd see
is death strip and if anyone tried to
escape or move over there I could death
somebody would open fire
so far in this trip I've been looking at
the Berlin Wall and issues related to
the Berlin Wall but what was like to
live in East Germany I have several
friends who grew up in the East and
they've tried to explain it to me but
I've never got a chance to actually
understand it at least here at the DDR
museum I'm gonna see what life was like
in East Germany so let's go in
in my opinion the fall of the Berlin
Wall was one of the greatest events of
the 20th century if I had a time machine
I would love I would do anything to go
back to be in Berlin on November 9th
1989 this is a fabulous trip and thank
you for coming with me on my Berlin Wall
DDR roadtrip hopefully we'll see you in
Berlin really soon
among Berlin's many attractive features
are the numerous rivers and lakes in and
around the metropolitan area along with
the river spey countless canals
crisscross the city one great way to
admire Berlin's historic center is by
boat and on hot summer days bathers can
choose from over 20 lakes and 11 open
air pool lake van se has one of the
oldest beaches
the finest sand brought specially from
the Baltic Sea coast vans a bathing
beach has room for more than 40 thousand
people to relax and enjoy the lakeside
in the 1920s it was planned to make vans
a beach a cosmopolitan open-air Lido of
monumental proportions then the world
financial crisis of 1929 put an end to
the high-flying plans only the first
phase of construction was completed in
the functional style known as noisily
kite new objectivity axle aunt has been
keeping a watchful eye on swimmers for
43 years he's the longest serving beach
attendant in the complex and probably
its biggest fan yeah that's one bad 1zv
zapier one's a beach has such atmosphere
you come in and look out over the lake
towards Claude oh and Gatto over
Hecker's horn the sand is almost like in
the Caribbean we have more than a
kilometre of beach if you sit and watch
the sunset over chuan and vada Island
you'll cancel your holiday buy a season
ticket and become a regular here the
work hardens been here Tungus axel wants
to show us what was originally planned
for the bathing beach this is his home
these are old projections from 1928 this
is how the leader was originally
supposed to look in fact it was only
built after this embankment here on the
southern end and that was all in 1928 it
was planned to go as far as vans a pier
that's about another 800 meters okay
Lama - let me them here axel has many
more stories but we have to move on our
boat is about to leave from the pier
where the beach was originally supposed
to end
we're going into the city it'll take us
a good 3 hours on this excursion boat
one last look at the beach and then we
go past the buns a villas along the
river Hoffa towards the city center
captain Emo's Anita says Berlin has more
water than Stockholm some 200 kilometers
of navigable canals and about a thousand
bridges more water ways than Amsterdam
and Venice put together
he's been navigating Berlin's waterways
for 32 years
but he wasn't carnival they say Berlin
was built from barges in other words all
the building materials were brought to
Berlin on barges back then Berlin would
be unimaginable without water coal is
still brought on barges to high power
station during the Berlin Blockade it
supplied the isolated West Berliners
with electricity and ensured their
survival
after about two hours we approach the
city center passing a great deal of
modern architecture along the way after
German reunification a real construction
boom took place on the banks of this
play this is the German Chancellor's
office it was the first building in
what's now the federal government and
parliamentary quarter diagonally across
from it is the main railway station and
thousands of people enjoying the summer
sunshine but then the crosses behind the
high stock come into view a reminder
that in the past the waterway also meant
suffering here the Berlin Wall bordered
on this play and the virtually
uncrossable river itself formed part of
the border installation we get off
outside please leash class the railway
station and go into the palace of tears
where people crossing to the west from
East Berlin were once processed it got
its name from the farewell tears that
were shed now it contains a museum
documenting daily life in the divided
Germany you can learn about people such
as hi not Klaus who was an environmental
activist in the former East Germany he
repeatedly applied for permission to
leave the country and after many years
received it he remembers the exact
moment when a border official stamped
his passport yet somehow said then we'd
made it just a few meters through the
tunnel to the underground platform which
were all still each German territory but
we knew nothing could happen to us
anymore
our excursion comes to an end we
disembark at Museum Island and follow
the sounds of swing music on the
opposite bank
for five euros every Friday at Hunt
pamita the mother of all Berlin beach
bars you can learn the basics of swing
dancing on other days it's salsa or
tango always with a fantastic view of
museum Island
we'll now meet up with Miguel castaigne
Venegas from Colombia to stroll around
the popular district of Kreuzberg and
Roy Cohn the hip and colorful shops and
eateries in the neighborhoods here are
particularly popular with young people
from all around the world every district
has its own flavor and character and
that makes every stroll through the city
an adventure
hola todos hi my name is Miguel I come
from Colombia I spent the night on this
ship it's hard to believe it's in Berlin
in Kreuzberg I've heard that this
district is very interesting come with
me
this hostel offers a great experience
yeah mine are yo Sam me parece it's
something special because it's between
the wall and the spray River in the
middle of Berlin simply unbelievable
Man 1 it's very exciting for me to walk
along the wall listen the whole world
knows about the Berlin Wall
everyone's heard of it then I can be
here see it get to know it love you look
on sale oh hey is that that money what a
lovely view the buildings along the
river looked like warehouses look and
there's a boy and there's a strange
sculpture there in the background
it's the onion
it's not any butter now we're in the
district of Nye :
look look an old photo booth you don't
get these in Colombia I'll make a few
photos in a minute
in Colombia in Colombia a lot of people
would just take the booth I'm taking
this as a souvenir I like them and we
are lots of hats here
as in Canaan it's incredible what there
is to see in Nikon they're making cotton
candy here apparently it's not being
made to eat but for an art piece in a
gallery what does this sculpture mean we
want to portray paradise they're meant
to be clouds fill your groc I've never
seen anything so creative
I'll go tank it at the end city where do
you come from Colombia this toy is not
good this is Michael and this represents
everything that makes it what it is
do you indeed I had a great day I hope
you enjoyed it to tellen salut
and that's all for this special edition
of discover Germany the Travel Guide
here on DW see you next time
you
you